if you get venom in this trailer venom
in the game oh man would that be good I
would be like a [ __ ] in the rain high
reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm humble
Soros Rex what's there's a new
spider-man trailer out for the gameplay
launch trailer for the past four up here
do we go before we do that page from the
day shadow for a very handsome gentleman
Curt Anderson whose birthday it was
yesterday
Curt we did not have a video to go up on
YouTube I'm sorry about that buddy but I
wanted to say happy belated birthday to
you right now I hope you're having a
good time Bonnie wood family hanging out
with friends banging some decent looking
chicks just do whatever you can to live
up your 30th birthday I'm assuming you
look like you're probably younger but
I'm gonna go for the 30s and I hope you
get to travel some more this year you've
only hit up 49 states you got one more
to go I hope you get that done keep that
Nomad life rolling and happy birthday to
you
Wow
I know yeah wait till you find the
sinister six that buy it's gonna be epic
yeah
that's like the old teaser reminds me
now it's just another trailer to remind
you that this games coming out in a
couple weeks
yeah they you know doesn't really offer
too much new stuff just really defying
that this game is gonna be epic this
game's gonna have good graphics it looks
like it's gonna actually get you excited
to watch all those cutscenes yeah kind
of feels like an interactive movie yeah
you know oh yeah a little bit I mean
this is at least this footage is super
cinematic and that one I mean when he's
got the helicopters webbed up between
the buildings I thought of that original
teaser from the first movie or I love
that shot too when he's like going into
the car goes out the other other window
and then catches it yeah it's just as
good as Andrew Garfield than the Amazing
Spiderman maybe even slightly better
maybe even better than the amazing
spider-man 2 I just really hope that
Tony Stark can show up in this yeah I
hope you later character yeah and then
you get to do a mission retake Peters
suit away from sex and wide to
discipline your men we all know how this
games gonna end we all know this game's
gonna end Peter's gonna be looking at
Tony mr. stark I don't feel so good
press a and B rapid and not to disappear
or exit circle whatever whoever's
console we're on I kind of have a slight
theory a very minor theory here that I
don't think anyone shares with me and is
probably gonna tell me I'm 100% wrong
did that guy's Miles Morales yeah and
[Laughter]
Peter's gonna die at the end of this
game it's gonna be a hand me off to
Miles Morales that's just my theory that
could be cool let's do that kind of like
what happens in the comics with Miles
Morales the storyline I don't think
they're gonna like obey the comic
storyline I think though that would be a
cool hand me off to do hey man it seems
like we're slowly cresting into Miles
Morales is time I mean you've got into
the spider-verse and now you've got him
in this yeah there's a lot of looks like
we could get that live action Miles
Morales in the near future I think the
only thing that's missing from these
trailers to make it ultimate because you
have the sinister six in here you got a
wide variety of villains and beyond the
sinister six evil black widow if you get
venom in this trailer venom in the game
oh man
and would that be good when I cash it in
the rain they leave more potential in a
way that's less obnoxious than in a
movie for having like a bunch of other
villains you just want to have in your
game even if yeah the focal villains you
know the big bosses are wrong yeah yeah
I'm also thinking if you can't get miles
like as this as the lead in the second
one maybe there's gonna be like a DLC
for him to be in this game - that'd be
fun that would be funny fun I wanted
like a survival horror spider-man game
is what I really want is like to have
him like you know in a haunted house
with like really limited webs you gonna
find time to like cook up your own web
juice again like between zombie attacks
or whatever it is or no you could have
who's the vampire villain Morbius
Morbius there which was incidentally I
heard who's Sam Raimi wanted for
spider-man for how you feel about the
choice of music in this trailer job you
know there was music I didn't really
retain a lot of it since we saw the
video I mean for like you know the black
characters just like oh they did a black
panther you slapped much of rap music on
it and they're doing the same thing here
as Peter Parker that's right is a member
of the black community and hardcore rap
music and it's remember when you see
like black people and trailers you
always you're people why they gotta put
a rap music on it yeah well yeah that's
what I'm saying now I don't really mean
it for all these comments come and make
fun of that I don't know we can't be
sarcastic no no more sarcasm people now
after we said that people hired us from
she's from they elbowed the fourth wall
he's from Jim Rick's animation that's
right DreamWorks Animation presents
brave
we got clarifies something really quick
we know she's from Pixar
oh yeah oh god please it's a job so
who's taking more of the half of the ps4
word evitable going to have to buys you
mmm do you want a place to pay for 70%
cuz you play more than me for at some
point
Oh as you're saying well you buy it and
I'll pay you back in increments that's
fair as long as I get priority time for
Devil May Cry 5 of them no no I will
scraps of the usage I mean John my
birthday is four days before this comes
out if you were a good friend you'd buy
it for me I'm just saying I'll buy I'll
preorder you the game but you got a girl
I think if you should get the
PlayStation and I'll get I'll get the
game I'll don't worry I'll get the game
I'll consider it it's alright I already
got you something for your birthday you
did yes yeah you never get me anything
in advance I had a birthday or Christmas
as always your presents come you never
got me something and every my birthday
it's always like I think your present
going to be super duper late and then it
shows up early yeah that's our union you
know in a gift shaped bubble alright
guys well if you want to get me
spider-man for my birthday just hit me
up on Instagram I'll send you an address
we're starting to go fund me to get us a
peaceful we need a ps4 immediately guys
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification Bell cuz
subscribe buttons you know don't do
anything and you could check us out on
patreon where we got [ __ ] I'll see you
later